hey guys hope you enjoy today's marathon
of season one of tasties making a big
make sure to stick around for the whole
video because at one point I'm gonna be
presenting three options of giant foods
to choose from for season two and I want
you guys to pick that for me so until
then enjoy the marathon and stick around
14 pounds of beef 10 pounds of dough 6
pounds of cheese this burger is gonna be
56 times size of a regular burger hey
guys my name is Alvin I'm a tasty
producer and I love making crazy food
and my friend Victor actually hit me up
yesterday and he is a guy that just
loves burgers to the end of the world
and he goes I got a favor to ask you
know I like burgers right well you see
my birthday's coming up real soon and I
don't really like King and I was
wondering could you make me a giant
cheeseburger for my birthday but I was
like dang ok I see you're I hit me up
tomorrow and see what I can do
thanks many of the goat so dude good
what you got for me gonna have the
couple of my favorite burgers I wanted
you to come check it out what do you
love so much about this burger it starts
off with this amazing toasted brioche
bun toasting it on both sides to make
sure there's crispy and the beef the way
that they sear it
the juiciness bang and that cheese that
cheese though it melts into all the
little crevices of the beef so I'm
talking about and the top things are
super simple lettuce tomato
oh man once you put all those wonderful
things together you take that bite
[Music]
so I'm gonna try to make you a really
big version of this might not be easy
but I'm gonna see what I can do if
anybody can do is you man all right
thanks doing pretty good time to make
this crazy thing we're gonna start with
his giant custom brioche bun pretty
classic Rios recipe some flour some salt
sugar a couple of eggs gonna get this
started
I forgot the dough hook while this is
going I'm gonna make the starter mixture
a cup of water yeast some milk for the
yeast to drink kind of get hydrated
start drinking got growing because you
know the Z's ain't hit puberty yet ooh
five to eight minutes low speed until
the dough comes together and then we're
gonna add a lot of butter the dough is
coming together it's in a ball shape of
brioche one of the most signature things
a lot of butter so add it slowly
coorporate into the dough and kind of
make it super velvety so let's look at
hot good a lot of dough y'all that's
nice
cool yeah shape it to a ball get this
guy into this buttered dish bed get some
plastic cover this guy up let him take a
nap for two hours and I'll see you in a
bit dude so while the dough rest want to
use some foil to kind of make the bun
stay in this shape gotta make a circle
class but to give there's this sort of
thing this is a big-ass circle hope it's
dirty you have to hold the bread but
we'll see oh man
this is a big boy right here here we go
so satisfying whoa
maybe I should have oiled my surface get
the air bubbles out reshape it into the
form of a circle for the hamburger bun
so the rest of you for this dough
actually makes ten individual buns and I
doubled the recipe so this bun is
actually gonna be the size of 20 buns I
think I'm gonna put some egg wash on
this too off to the oven you go see you
in a minute
[Music]
this is a big button whoa that is a
burger button then directly into the pan
looking pretty good
well this one kind of toast in the pan
I'm just gonna brush some butter on this
gonna throw it in the broiler over there
to get toasted too oh that's a nice
toast now we're gonna make this beef
patty I got the biggest tray we could
find in the kitchen I got a lot of beef
but not with a lot of people and it is
14 pounds of beef in an average burger
somewhere around 1/4 pound this burger
is gonna be 56 times a regular burger oh
wait gloves let's get to work I don't
think I've ever seen this much meat in
my life you know when I went to the
grocery store to get this lady in line
behind me was like boy you hungry
and I was like you bet I am a visual
representation between Machine Gun Kelly
and M&M all right that's all the beef
it's like working with dough but not
really because the dough's meat time to
season garlic powder onion powder smoked
paprika a lot of pepper
make it rain boy like almost like a
quarter cup of salt don't be afraid to
season your meat y'all oh wait I need to
take my watch off before this get any
crazier and to make it all evenly
combined it's a lot harder than I
thought it was gonna be I think I've
seen salt Bay through some of these
videos getting tired thing is wild never
was the trainer like hey here's a 14
pounds of ground meat do five reps whoo
all right it's been seven years let's
say this meat is thoroughly mixed and
figure out how to get it into a patty
shape second pan please thanks Brenda
appreciate it
this is one patty the second one I'm
gonna make it into a perfect circle
outsides thicker than inside because
when a burger cooks it actually shrinks
it's a meat pizza whoo that's one all
right let's go for another one I'm
changing to a slapping technique this is
how you train as a masseuse oh I don't
have a pan that can sear so what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna put him in the
oven 300 degrees to kind of cook them
all through and then when I turn on the
broiler really nice caramelization on
top to get all the flavor patties are
done I need to deal with the cheese
though
[Music]
so we're gonna make the big cheese slice
now a lot of people might be saying hey
why don't you just put a bunch of cheese
slices on top of the patty itself I mean
you could but we're a tasty we're making
a big so why not just make a giant
cheese slice Oh a peaceful half American
cheese half cheddar cheese
let it cook down let it melt a little
bit if you are lactose intolerant look
away now we about to go in that's a good
cheese right there
oh my mom ah look at this alright we got
work fast before it starts to get cold
this also may or may not be too much
cheese but there's no such thing as too
much cheese where's that spatula
one last smooth these cheese slices
gonna go in the fridge see you in a bit
oh it has hot oh my that's so hot so
these cheese slices have firmed up
pretty nicely put these on here trim
these up a bit save these snacks for
later looking good you know sometimes I
dream of crazy things this is how these
slices are made good I made my own
custom cheese slice these are the
biggest cutting boards I have ever seen
I didn't even know we had stuff this big
so we're gonna see if this actually
works
yeah okay I think that's pretty cool and
may have overestimated how much cheese I
needed but there's nothing wrong with
more cheese we're put these back in the
oven until they're nice and really
delicious and we're gonna build this
burger oh this just got so much heavier
I will see you when you are nice and
melty about oh that I like to see I
think it looks great
I just kind of want to eat it right now
but I can't because Victor's got to eat
it buns are toasted garnishes are ready
burgers ready patties ready I think it's
time to build this burger I'm actually
pretty nervous for it there's like 14
pounds of beef ten pounds of dough six
pounds of cheese here we go all right
big hand Eagles yes Daddy number two is
landed
I think the bun might be a little too
small but that's okay
there this oh this is looking cool nice
floral arrangement Santa's come together
I think you could probably fit a piece
of this in your mouth
nice bit of lettuce tomatoes how's that
song go
I got beans greens tomatoes potatoes yam
something one and two and time to do the
top button in the sauce this is some
secret burger sauce I made Mayo some
mustard some ketchup some pickle juice
that's pretty much it I took this
toasted burger button then just kind of
spread it nice and evenly over it all
right here we go got to put the cat on
the Hat
might not be a big enough hat come on
okay the top of the bun shrunk a little
bit more than I thought it was going to
but that's okay this burger is pretty
much done I'm going to go get Victor and
it's his birthday today I really want to
know if it actually tastes good so I'm
gonna wash my hands and we're gonna go
surprise it's just like 25 pounds sub
Vic so have event this is the size of a
regular burger correct yes sir close
your eyes awesome I can't wait
Wow why did that sound like that ready
ready 1 2 3 open your eyes Nick Becky
who grows like the same thing let's just
be huge how many burgers do you think
would fit in this part for like 20 of
those burgers in here easy the first
thing I thought of was just how
beautiful it looks unbelievable let's
bite into this bad boy I can't wait to
try it then I really can't wait to try
it
oh that's the fake burger to seize maybe
could be [ __ ] lame that's a proper
serving size
that's what I'm talking about
how do you get to be so juicier he
toasted them you toasted the buns bro
we're not wasting any of this I think
I'm gonna have to call down some friends
bro huh just bring in the back dog
feeding a lot of my friends at this
giant burger and just watching them
finish at all it really made me happy
granny's new button might have been a
little small that she's little too big
this time
but seeing people smile and being able
to make them happy with food that is the
best feeling in the world for me so if
you've got a favorite food comment below
hit me up send me a DM and I will do my
very best to try and make it big for you
until then
[Music]
we have like 20 pounds of dough for this
doughnut I don't think this table is big
enough I think it's time to go big or go
home
this is the biggest note I've ever seen
[Music]
hi my name is Alvin I'm a tasty producer
and I love making big food so yesterday
I got an Instagram message from a
bodybuilder where they handle no
doughnuts here and he says hey dude I
have an idea I saw the giant burger
video and tomorrow is my cheat day I was
wondering if you could make me a giant
doughnut oh man
that sounds crazy how big hey got any
big to get big awesome that's what I
like to hear hit me up tomorrow and I'll
see what I can do and I've also been
getting a lot of requests to make a
giant doughnut so I feel like I know
what I'm gonna make today how are you
yeah nice to see you yeah likewise but
the people that don't know you what do
you do I am a cop cop slash fitness
person I've been a cop for over eleven
years now but I've used social media as
a platform to encourage first responders
look out their lifestyles what is this
story behind your social media my handle
is no donuts here kind of poking fun at
the donut eating cop stereotype if you
want to command presence and look
professional you know fitness plays a
huge part in that use what is your
relationship with food it has a lot to
do with whether you're storing fat
building muscle two days mostly to keep
you sane drop your carbs down really low
and you want to have a doughnut to fill
you out yeah make you feel good sounds
like today is your cheat day have you
worked out today yet not yet how about I
go make the big donut if you want to go
work out you can have a very fun cheat
meal for you who sounds like I'll need
that work out all right cool thanks dude
I'll see you in a bit all right
like this big donut for a big man first
thing we're gonna do we're gonna have to
make the donut dough is they used to
donut so we're gonna start by making the
east mixture some milk some warm water
some sugar and the East oh I just
spilled a little bit that's okay the
CSIs is gonna soak up all this nice
sugar all this nice milk really grow
into a big boy see you in a bit
so this donut takes a lot of flour and
and my mixing bowl is only this big so
I'm actually gonna be making two entire
batches of this dough ten entire cups of
flour
Oh white cloud some salt shortening four
eggs
hook this up to the dough mixer
delicious East mixture
oh god I'm spilling everywhere accidents
happen
that's fine stay clean the funny thing
is even one of these batches makes about
twenty to thirty Donuts and I'm doubling
it so there's going to be enough dough
for like forty to sixty Donuts I think
it's time to go big or go home
I really don't want to go home whoa look
at all that dough let's get you out of
here put it into this big bowl this is
the biggest bowl we have in the tasty
kitchen get out of there come on dude
it's the most dorm held in my entire
life I would not be a good rapper whoa
okay gluten coming that's only one we
got to make another batch
I told my mom I was gonna go and make
that dough I don't think she knew that
this is what I meant we have like 20
pounds of dough in here for this
doughnut that was fun butin strands are
like super tight right now we want them
to relax I'm gonna go in and take a long
nap for the big times all right
how we'll see you and I will see you a
bit now let's make the glaze for the
doughnut so the glaze is pretty simple
we just have some melted butter it's
kind of a lot of butter but more butter
more better funny thing is the original
glaze recipe makes enough for about 10
to 15 doughnuts we're making a really
big hunt so I tripled the recipe I think
this batch of pink glaze is gonna be
enough for 30 to 45 normal doughnuts so
the butter is melted we're gonna add in
some milk 3 cups of powdered sugar that
cloud reminds me of something else snow
so as a lot of lumps got a nice whisk
here whip it through the glass whoa
looking pretty nice my strip is going on
here so at this point we're gonna add
the color literally the ingredient is
the color pink
I hope this is pink hold on oh okay
let's think we're good one drop of the
color pink
oh I added two look at that two drops
did that that's that's pretty pink
deliciousness right there can't have a
giant donut without giant sprinkles for
reference these are normal rainbow
sprinkles this is the size of one
sprinkle you guys know cause sprinkles
are made cuz I sure did it before this
when take some powdered sugar some corn
syrup some cornstarch and some water
I think that's literally it wrinkles
have colors I have like 10 bajillion
things of food coloring here so we're
gonna divide this into 10 billion bowls
and then we're gonna color it one two
three four came through dripping good
guy red yellow green
blue yo blue what's going on min-woo I
don't want too much it doesn't need a
little bit alright there's blue and
purple
all right yellow you better represent us
well oh that's looking nice boom
purple is done so we're in them all up a
little bit and I need to get each color
individually into the piping bag so a
little trick take a cup put your piping
bag with the tip in it right that chance
for the glaze see if this works
that's so cool that feeling when you're
like cutting through paper and
kindergarten you just glide right on
with the scissors that's what this feels
like
next color you're gonna pick up where I
left off training number two blue I love
that last but not least purple all right
I know you really can't see it but this
is the size of one sprinkle this is
quite the size difference I'll let these
dry out and I'll see you in a bit all
right let's see how big my dough has
gotten sweet baby Jesus look at this one
you went like straight through puberty
and hit menopause to get the flower here
we go come on
get out of there oh damn look at that
glutton oh look at you I'm working a
little bit knock some of the air out of
it and then we're going to get it back
into a ball shape it's got some weight
to it look at this absolute unit right
there it's good tucked underneath LeBron
James this guy is gonna relax for a bit
and then we are going to shape them into
an actual doughnut so one thing that I
should have probably thought about was
the how big this doughnut is gonna be so
this is the biggest pan we actually have
I don't think this pan is gonna cut it I
have a friend who's a chef nearby I'm
hoping that he has something bigger so
let me message him and see what he says
hey super random question but what is
the size of your biggest pan I got a
stupid big wok it's 30 inches five
dollar bill for reference holy moley I'm
coming over 30 inches is the entire
width of this table so his walk is gonna
be like this big so I got to turn this
ball of dough into a perfect donut ring
my baby this is kind of fun I've never
really have to use my forearms to need
before gonna start in the middle and
work your way out how we looking
yeah that's not big enough I don't think
this table is big enough how to get him
into a circle I'm gonna interlock these
two ends over here birds-and-the-bees am
i right
whoa now I got to figure out how to
transport this all the way to the
restaurant large piece of cardboard
covered and parchment paper and taped
together in the back so here we go let's
go for it
all right we can reshape it that's okay
all right you little kid over here
you're gonna cover this in plastic wrap
and then we're gonna head over to the
restaurant all right someone call me an
uber
[Music]
fellas hey you don't go there call out
big-ass donut yeah oh we got this big
ass walk for you Oh 30 where'd you get
this
I got in Chinatown Oh 300 a case you got
yeah I think give it another like four
more minutes how are you gonna flip this
hair somebody uses two tongs okay
and then somebody uses two of the ladles
do not do this at home this is very
dangerous he is a skilled professional
this is heavy yeah can it go deeper
under our culture I think we need a
better tool okay oh I don't know if it's
gonna stay together yeah me neither
how does a good taking maybe we should
have some emerged I think we can get it
to work so I'm gonna make another batch
we're not gonna let this little ways now
this was chop it up and make it
okay you want to use it I'll take it all
right cool let's see you know big guy
Eric I made another doughnut around -
here we go
that's hot let's do it that's going in
yep whoa beautiful so this goes in okay
we're gonna submerge it to make sure
that it can cook even more evenly yeah
yes yes and we'll press it down with
heavy stuff have a textbook Jack's book
plates two on each side this is a very
DIY situation it's called problem
solvers is what Columbia University it
doesn't teach you so I think this is
gonna cook herb what like 20 25 minutes
or check back in a bit to see if we can
flip it this is looking pretty good if
you look at it looks really beautiful
super super crispy we are going to try a
super hard task of flipping it because
last time this is where I failed all
right let's take off these weights 1 2 3
whoa dude this thing huge wow this is
nice nice don't know yeah little white
spot in the back oh we're gonna cook it
once it flipped over and then I'll trim
off in any that doesn't look good all
right get out of there oh I just want to
see how heavy this is
oh who the hell will have e to the
treatment okay so we're gonna get under
here can you help me get this onto the
tray yes yeah oh look at it I can't
solve that oh here we go good
you got it you got it yeah okay so whoa
look at that
oh let's go yes this is crazy
we did it look at that that's awesome
looks like a cross between a bagel
doughnut this is the biggest nut I've
ever seen
this is the Homer doughnut it's a big
zero because that's how many calories
there are don't think that's how it
works you get on oh great
nice job there all right got the back go
yes okay we got it
yeah all right cool careful the hot oil
coming unit go
tray underneath God do some ASMR while
the worst
[Music]
I'm not doing that every good thanks
dude see you man have a good one
best of luck all right we are back and
we are going to make this big donuts get
my sprinkles
I made some white sprinkles because I
forgot to do that and after seeing how
big the donut was I doubled how much
glaze I have all you need to do is cut
these giant sprinkles into their shape
and we can finally glaze and sprinkle
the donut
[Music]
damn it's a nice pretty cool right here
I accidentally hit someone with this
this might be assault with a deadly
weapon
more like salt with delicious weapon
alright these sprinkles are ready to go
I think it's time to glaze this donut
make sure there's no lumps in looking
good this might get messy oh hey look at
this glaze waterfall so we gotta put on
those sprinkles before everything starts
to set so all the colors I think this is
done here we go hey Mike yeah do you
want your donut oh I'm ready
alright close your eyes we're coming is
this solo heavy we needed two people to
lift it there one two three open your
eyes no way are you kidding me this is
what you expected when I said I was
gonna make you a giant I wasn't thinkin
this big this is insane take this got to
be twenty thirty pound and cut piece for
you oh man that's like we go nuts right
there whoa this is for you alright
cheers Mike cheers happy cheat day yeah
dude it was pretty good perfect crispy
on the outside soft on the inside ice
was great it's a lot of cheat days going
up mm-hmm I was really good
I'm I have to take this whole thing home
thanks dude thank you guys all right bye
Mike bye guys
all right have a good one yeah see you
later see you later so that will
probably be the biggest donut I will
ever see or make in my entire life I
love making these crazy things so if you
have a favorite food if you have an idea
that you want me to try to make huge hit
me up leave a comment send me an
Instagram message and I will see if I
can make that bakery if you actually
want to go to restaurants that serve
these crazy things
my friend Jasmine has a giant food
series on bring me that is really really
cool so you should go check it out until
next time peace things are about to get
a little messy what'd I do wrong work
there's no time for weakness whoa
fantastic oh my god open your eyes oh
that's no hazing
hi I'm Alvin I'm a tasty producer and I
love making giant this season on tasty
is making a big I'm going to be making
giant food for friends people that I
admire and people that I've always
wanted to meet I've always admired
competitive eaters and today I've
invited Ryan up Wong a competitive eater
who also does amazing food challenges on
her Channel let's go meet her and see
what kind of [ __ ] wants me to make
how's it going nice to meet you how did
you start to get into competitive eating
my first-ever food challenge without any
kind of practice was a four pound
burrito and then I managed to finish
that in six minutes four pound burrito
how large was that it was like this but
it was fat oh my god that is crazy is
that you're most proud eating
accomplishment I actually have the world
record in and out wait really yeah I
have I ate a 50 by 50 in one sitting it
is 50 patties and 50 slices of cheese so
it was literally like this long I want
to make a giant food challenge for you
today obviously you've eaten a lot of
crazy thing but if you were to pick one
food for me to make for you what do you
think could be fun um you know what I've
actually done a lot of food challenges
but I never seen giant chicken nuggets
or a giant fries I did a chicken nugget
challenge okay 100 chicken nuggets in
four minutes but not a huge one okay
well sounds like I have a pretty big
task ahead of me I want to see if I can
make something that you know will stand
up to your athletic prowess so I might
be a couple hours but I hope you're
hungry I am all right cool I'll go to
the kitchen the giant chicken nuggets
and giant fries they're not the newest
thing some popular YouTube channels have
done them already but we're gonna do our
own version and see where it takes us I
think it'll be nice to freshly grind
some chickens so we have boneless
skinless chicken thighs this is 7 pounds
sounds like a lot that's because it is
you know we're gonna do these in batches
because I don't think I'll be able to
grind all this chicken at the same time
it goes nothing
that's what I like to see in the morning
may or may not look gross to you but
ever had a hot dog a burger or a sausage
it's basically the same thing I'm also
using chicken thighs
I like the thighs over breasts because
the thighs are to sear there's more fat
I think that'll add a lot more flavor to
the final chicken nugget one last grind
here we go and it's not working
what'd I do wrong work oh the top goes
pop goes that way this is why you stay
in school kids mmm delicious
so this is seven pounds of ground
chicken I'm going to season it because
you always have to season your meat so
we have some salt coarsely ground black
pepper garlic powder some onion powder
so nothing too crazy to give this a nice
old mix here so this is our chicken
mixture seasoned nicely and now we are
going to shape it into chicken nugget
shapes things are about to get a little
messy oh boy this is appetizing fast
food nuggets they have four different
shapes a bell a bone a boot and a ball
I'm just gonna start with the easiest
first I'm just gonna make a ball any
DJ's out there probably can remix that
[Music]
it's what they call a slapper I want to
say that's that's the ball shape we're
gonna make three more so I'm gonna grind
21 pounds more and we're gonna make
three other shapes
yes our second shape is the Bell it's
kind of like an egg I want to say that's
the bell the bone has got like this kind
of weird little thing sticking out it's
got a peninsula that's a word I learned
in geography class this is apparently
the bone last one
we got the boot it just basically click
like the bone and then to someone like
Photoshop is stretched it out a little
bit don't think I'll wear this boot this
chicken I would say this is pretty much
done I'll put these in the oven and I'll
see you in a bit okay so while the
chicken is baking in the oven I'm gonna
start making from the fries my initial
idea was to fry just one whole potato
but then I was like it's not big enough
Alvin come on what are you doing it's
not the name of the show we're gonna go
for something a lot bigger
it starts with 5 pounds of potatoes so
this is going to boil until they're
really four tender and cooked it's a lot
of potatoes it might take a while so
I'll see you guys in probably 10 years
whenever this water decides to boil I'm
gonna go take a nap now was a good nap
see how these potatoes are doing okay
look pretty cooked a little more
appetizing than chicken God do a little
Q C okay Idaho I found a really cool toy
in the back that we're gonna use to mash
these this is really awesome look at
this guy or throw some potatoes in here
and see if this actually works
oh okay it is official I like this toy
let's load this up with some more
potatoes here we go
that's like G's coming out holy moly
just like in the club make it ready I
don't think this is structurally stable
enough to make the fries so I'm gonna
put in some corn starch season with some
salt to taste we're just gonna give it a
nice mix the consistency is like normal
mashed potatoes it's kind of like that
feeling if you've ever made like instant
mashed potatoes but it's a little bit
more crumbly I don't want this to be wet
if it's wet it goes in the fryer that's
just bad oil and water are like
arch-nemesis you know they just fight
it's that shot you know when the super
hero and the super villain they both do
their ultimate move and it meets in the
middle and the whole world blows up kind
of want to avoid that happening I got
the biggest tray we could find in the
tasty kitchen we're gonna make and shape
some fries I'm gonna be generous and say
this entire mixture makes about like
four fries or so so I think I can just
shape these into a nice long french
fries shape this is an ancient technique
swim passed down for generations the
fast-food industry would kill for these
secrets that's actually looking pretty
good I would say and I got my trusty
tools to help me get these really
straight I think that's one good look at
fry this little smooth pat down on the
top
Oh shape I gave him a haircut last one
the Big Daddy the head honcho oh there
you have it five pounds of potatoes for
fries not bad
think I'm gonna go make another four cuz
you don't just eat for fries come on eat
like 20,000 I'm gonna put these in the
freezer and I'm gonna check on the
chicken to see how they look and I'm
gonna go wash my hands because there's
potatoes everywhere
look at these bad boys right here oh my
god I think my favorite honestly is
going to be this boot before I said this
is a boot that I don't think anybody
would wear I've changed my mind
I will rock these any day of the week I
want to make a batter I don't want to
make a dry dredge when you have them at
the fast-food restaurants they're crispy
they're light the airy I think those are
the signs of a liquid batter they also
have a very large Hotel pan to make this
batter in because this nugget will not
fit normal pan all right first thing you
got some flour cornstarch sugar baking
powder then for some seasoning and
spices we have some paprika probably one
of my favorite spices ginger ground
dried ginger some allspice and some
white pepper all right I just got some
white pepper in my mouth Oh what if my
nose too it's like kind of stinging
whenever I apply a remote technique not
the most efficient but saves you from a
lot of pain okay that settled for eggs
boop-boo-boo-boop and then just some
good old h2o keep in mind this is for
one chicken nugget over here for quite a
while this is a really thick batter it's
gonna give it a nice crust it's just
very hard to waste one Ellen I'll make
this time there's no time for weakness
okay well batter smooth now it's time to
head into the kitchen heat up some oil
and do some really dangerous things
maybe I should not have said that
so we are in the commercial kitchen at
tasty we have a very large pot of oil
that is very hot please do not try this
at home but we have some fries to fry
and we have some chicken nuggets and
some batter to fry I want to try it with
the fries first to see how it goes to be
very careful with how I do this here
goes nothing we're gonna get one of
these really big spiders and just to
make sure that this doesn't stick oh I
hate a chunk off I won't touch it this
oil is currently at 375 which is hotter
than the normal 350 because it just
helps get a harder crust whoa oh you did
it yo this is looking fantastic oh my
gosh I'm gonna call it I think this is
done so I'm gonna take it out I want to
do this like seven four times and then
we're gonna fry some nuggets after that
I think this is actually the most
nerve-wracking part is this big giant
chicken nugget I have the batter here
right next to the oil so it doesn't need
to go that far when I attempt to get
this in the oil as safe as I can so
first we're gonna put on some gloves
gonna get this guy into the batter
OOP this little bath you got there Bob I
named this guy Bob well that's a thick
batter okay it's gonna be a little
tricky cuz he's so heavy come on Bob all
right we're gonna go slow here we go
whoo there it is and we got a air bubble
not the smoothest landing it's kind of
mad right now Bob's pissed I put him in
400 degrees fighting so we're gonna let
him hang out oh okay it's getting crispy
already lucky
chicken nugget crust if you like you
know made me stand 300 feet away and was
like what does this look like I'll be
like that's a fast-food chicken nugget
all right I'm gonna go in
that's a chicken nugget right there whoo
seven pounds of chicken ground up baked
for 35 minutes battered and fried at 400
degrees for like two minutes and now you
get a giant chicken nugget
can you hear that like oh that's crispy
right there something that is this big
that is fried you gotta let it hang out
so we're gonna go Friday three more so I
want to need some coffee
whoo it's been a day I've been frying
for about three hours now but I think
the results are all worth it we got four
chicken nuggets one of every single
shape eleven fries I went a little
overboard when you get your nuggets and
fries in your fast food meal they don't
just come in an ordinary box no they
come in iconic packaging so I asked our
art department to make some really cool
packaging for our nuggets and fries and
we're gonna put them in there it's just
a four piece chicken nugget set but the
only thing is there's seven pounds of
chicken and it's not given so you got 28
pounds of chicken nuggets on deck I
think this looks pretty cool so let's
move on to the fries this is such an
awesome box look at that got some tall
ones got some short ones we got honey
mustard and we also have the good
old-fashioned ketchup okay so I want to
get these over to RINO because I think
she's hungry and I want to see how much
she wants to eat mine are you hungry
oh yeah all right well I have your food
can you close your eyes yeah oh boy this
is heavy
oh that smells like the chicken on the
count of three one two three open your
eyes oh my god oh you know a four-piece
meal for you oh thank you and a couple
of fries over there I hope this is a big
enough of a challenge for you
how do you feel I also got a
normal-sized portion of nuggets and
fries you just for comparison let's eat
all right I don't know how to start this
going deeper than that
Wow yeah Wow I'm chicken nuggets how
does it compare to a normal one yeah I
should have a lot more flavor sometimes
the food challenges I go to when they
make a big quantity the plot it usually
goes down mmm this one's okay all right
man you really Kenny that's crazy
I'm gonna try this part I feel a little
bit off here whoa whoa
uh-oh that was delicious I definitely
got through a good amount of that
chicken nugget Bobby the rest home for
dinner well thanks for coming in
hopefully you can feed the family with
the rest of this oh yeah definitely more
than enough all right oh thanks whoo
it's been a crazy day a lot of meats a
lot of potatoes a lot of frying a lot of
eating Brian ah she can eat a lot that
was crazy to witness in person you want
to take a guess at what I'm gonna make
next week send me a message on Instagram
drop it in the comments let me know got
some crazy stuff for you guys in the
store so until next time peace I've
never made a cake mix in this quantity
this is very very have you able to save
like 15 pounds of batter
open your eyes guys oh I'm a little
turned on right now I thank
sup guys to Melvin I love making giant
food and today on taste he's making a
big we're gonna do some crazy stuff Ned
and Zack from the try guys are coming in
I'm super excited because I've always
been a huge fan of their videos they do
these crazy things and they never back
down from a challenge I don't think I
will either I'll be challenging myself
to make the giant food of their dreams
so let's go see what they all mean to
make from them so guys guys haven't seen
you for a while you guys been up to
something in the last year we launched a
new YouTube channel youtube.com slash
and try guys and now we are going on a
nationwide tour we have a new book
coming out June 18 it's all the hidden
power of yeah what's this book about a
self-help book from for people that
can't help themselves
you guys are like no strangers to like
food videos yeah we love making food
videos and that has a food series
actually fun fact Ned and I are the
brunch boys of the tribes fun no get
some man's memos okay guys are you guys
guys what do you what's your perfect oh
I think we all know that the grated we
know we're both obviously the same thing
one two three watch what it sounds like
you guys have different opinions on what
your favorite food might be I'm gonna
make something giant for you guys what
should I make
look I don't think you're gonna get a
waffle iron big enough that is true
here's the gauntlet I'm throwing Duggar
if you make me a giant fluffy pancake
okay it's delicious
perhaps you can convince me okay alright
guys I'm gonna get to work I'll see you
guys in a bit you guys feel free to hang
out but I'm gonna see if I can make your
dream come true
I'm gonna see I can create one of your
first memories of pancakes to be the
best thing ever
[Music]
let's make these pancakes you're gonna
be pretty big so we have a lot of batter
to get through
dumping a lot of eggs and we're also
gonna dump it in a lot of milk oh you're
like the rappers in the music video they
like pour champagne this is actually a
family recipe it's been passed down for
many generations this one is by my aunt
we call her aunt J you know her very
very famous secret pancake recipe my
Uncle Ben kind of fights over it he'd
rather you know eat rice instead of
pancakes so that's kind of how it goes
ooh look nice so I don't know if you
guys have seen I made a 100 layer of
lasagna video and that one kind of used
foil as the walls I kind of want to take
that idea and make a pancake ring to
kind of cook in this pan over here do
some origami over here this ring goes
into this pan let that kind of hang out
give it a nice spray - the worst part
about making pancakes every time you
pour the batter into the pan it always
kind of gets everywhere I don't think
there's a solution for that okay so if
this pancake has been cooking for about
five to ten minutes it kind of looks
done on the side so let's give it a
check okay so batter on top was a little
raw that's fine if we flip it hopefully
it's okay well I don't know if you guys
can see that's burnt I don't think this
technique is working out so well so I
think the issue is I need a pan that's
thicker and bigger and we're gonna go
and try to find a bigger pain
oh wait this is perfect this is our pipe
and I think this is gonna work perfectly
so let's go for round two
okay let's put this big boy to work I
actually set up a double hot plate
situation because this guy's gonna need
a lot of heat I'm naming him Jim you
will be my guide for today and we're
going to see if you can make the big
package that I want to make this kind of
feels like I'm making a pancake for an
entire village
here we go
[Music]
that was an entire box of pancake mix
I'm a family recipe I'm gonna check it
when the edges are starting to firm up
and a lot of bubbles are coming through
and fingers crossed because this pan was
a godsend and want to make a big
pancakes so you guys so it's been like
20 minutes as you can see it's kind of
looking a little weird there's like a
ring of like semi-cooked batter on the
outside I'm gonna say it's pretty much
raw I think the issue is that there is
actually not enough heat to cook this
pancake through I don't hunt all this
batter to go to waste
so I'm gonna send this to the kitchen
and they're just gonna make some really
nice pancake bread pudding I'll be right
back
for a hopefully the correct attempt to
making this giant pancake because this
is heavy Jim is not cooperating right
now I have a plan for a different kind
of batter that I think we'll be able to
do correctly so we're just gonna melt a
lot of butter because everything tastes
better with it essentially what this is
it is a more of a japanese-style pancake
and essentially they made a lighter
batter that was more focused on egg
whites to help make it fluffy and
instead of cooking it directly on the
pan and flipping it they kind of cooked
it almost like an esteem we're in a
grill kind of oven situation so that
they rose a lot and they kept their
shape and the heat was even so when I
kind of go for that so this butter is
just going to melt down that's looking
pretty melted I'm just gonna take that
off on the next thing that we're gonna
do that was part of a lot of the
japanese-style pancakes was the egg
whites so that a nice trusty old stand
mixer here I'll name you Dave
Dave and we got Jim hanging out in the
back rusty buddies for this giant
pancake so just gonna get egg whites in
here so we're gonna whip these egg
whites until they get soft in Peaks and
then we're gonna fold them into the rest
of the batter so this we're gonna do the
melted butter and then we're gonna add
some warm milk
then we're gonna add in more beautiful
egg yolks nice and foamy pull in this
big bowl I'm gonna do flour and we're
gonna do some baking powder where they
get this in here oh look at Dave over
there he's doing work these egg whites
looking nice and fluffy thanks Dave
we're going to gently pull these in to
the batter I need to do the double
folding technique I'm pretty sure this
is not how we're supposed to do it
sorry pastry chefs sometimes you gotta
just roll with the punches pretty
optimistic about this batter so this is
nice
it is silky it looks pretty smooth so
we're just gonna transfer this to give
Jim hopefully one more last attempt
that's nice okay so I do want to smooth
this out a little bit this is very nice
very smooth I'm going to actually take
this to our grill and pray that it does
work so fingers crossed and I'll see you
guys out there oh you're a heavy boy Jim
is your name Dave I forgot so this is
our grill I'm glad that the pan fits
perfectly within the grill we're gonna
turn it on to about 300 or so degrees so
we're gonna get this guy hang out
hopefully it's fully cooked and really
nice and golden-brown by the end of it
pretty nervous so we'll see please it's
pin 45 minutes I hopefully think that's
enough time to cook this pancake I
really want to see what it looks like so
here we go
whoa this is crazy
holy crap it's like a giant souffle
biscuit which is pretty cool okay
there's a couple of cracks I think
that's fine we're gonna turn it out the
cracks are gonna be on the bottom
anyways all right let's go back and flip
this out
okay so we have one successful pancake
attempt the battle is not over yet we do
have to flip this guy but I think I'm
gonna put this tray on top and then kind
of do something like this this is really
really heavy okay what this guy looks
like oh this is a pancake that is right
it is a cake made in this pan it's like
so smooth it's like a baby's butt this
is one successful pancake for the try
guys I don't think they would be
satisfied with just one pancake I'm
gonna need to make at least four to five
more but before I do that I do want to
tackle the butter this is for entire
sticks of butter that have been softened
so if you think about it each stick of
butter has eight tablespoons so if we
use all of this we're gonna have a
butter score that's 32 times the size of
a normal butter square that's a lot of
butter I feel like I should name this
guy to call this guy Jimbo cuz we got
Jim and then we have Jimbo I'm gonna
stop talking now and put this butter
square in the freezer so see you guys
soon
[Music]
- oh boy here we go one two three okay
this is the second one okay that's - I
will name you this guy's Kevin this is
the third one okay better at this okay
okay you can be George - Oh easy for
hope you kind of fell off the plate a
little bit that's okay I know what to
name me right now it's okay I'll name
you later
sometimes you don't name your kids till
later hope my arms don't fail me oh
that's a nice-looking one I'll then this
guy Keith being here today but I'll name
a pancake after him oh this is the final
pancake oh that might be the best one
yet
I want to name this guy Eugene just like
Eugene pretty nice flawless skin so we
have one two three four five six giant
pancakes it has been a journey and the
only thing left is to assemble them so
we have all hands on deck sat all our
pancakes we got some bears you got some
syrup I'm going to try and be careful
with my children as much as I can all
right Jim first up where are all you
guys look alike oh my god Jim is very
resilient Jim can take a beating that's
why he goes on first because he's gonna
be under all the other children he's
gonna be taking all the pressure putting
the whole team on his back literally so
thanks Jim all right Kevin and Jim on
deck George has his two brothers
supporting him so he'll be able to rise
and shine just like the rest of us
and then fourth we got the problem child
the guy that I forgot to give a name oh
okay that's for Keith goes on keeps on
last but not least a more Eugene I think
he deserves if he's not here today I
think he deserves a little bit of a spot
like oh okay
that is oh that's a pretty big stack
okay makes me con here this is my piece
there is a sauce here we are finishing
touches I hoping that ends a car happy
with it if they eat it they'll be eating
Keith in Eugene first up this is for
entire sticks butter we got alright oh
there it is I don't really know how
heavy it is
I just want to see I can't even lift
that is definitely at least 50 pounds
and just so you guys can see this is a
normal sized stack of pancakes I would
say this is success I didn't think I
could be able to do this but I'm glad it
worked out I think it looks awesome and
I hope the try guys like it
Elva alum is so I have your pancakes
ready but first I just wanted you guys
to see the size of the serum so that was
saying there yeah so that tells you
anything about how this is gonna go I'll
be right back close your eyes okay okay
okay I'm really excited
oh thank you
well the pancakes are on the table on
the count of three I want you guys to
open your eyes and see what I made for
you one two three open your eyes guys
how do you feel that a waffle is ever
gonna stand up whoa could never stand
that tall how did you do so for this
pancake accent to get a paia pan so I
made a bunch of batter and we made six
of these big ones for you guys can I
touch it yes you can touch it this is
all yours
it's got nice nice outer yes this is
what your baby feels like everyone you
every time you do it whoo Oh what one
second I do have one more surprise for
you guys
hold on here now it's a brunch so I know
you guys talked about Mims
cheers Cheers
you guys want to start eating your
pancakes I will let you guys do the
syrup pouring the park yeah
oh my god we have giant pancakes but we
have regular-sized Forks and I for you
Jori pancakes is you got to get more
than one layer in a fight okay good you
have a nice crispness to the top there's
a top layer but then very fluffy on the
inside yeah so Zach how do you feel now
now you've had this stack do change your
mind about pancakes oh you can make me
pancakes whenever you want that's what I
like to hear
whoo I'm actually personally curious to
see a cross-section you have to feed it
to us oh here you go careful of the
knife the knife is at the bottom in the
middle take even better my hands are
sticky but thank you we love to brunch
but I think the joy of brunch is also
the joy of sharing and I like love if we
could share this with people here that
sounds a good idea I'm gonna go call
some friends I think love pancakes and
we're gonna bring them in to help you
demolish this brunch team assemble
[Music]
whoa it's been a crazy fun adventure
made a lot of pancakes but I'm really
happy that Ned and Zach enjoyed why I
made for them you want to take a guess
at what I'm gonna be making next feel
free to drop it in the comments send me
a message I'll be doing a lot of crazy
things and I can't wait to show you guys
what I have in store so until then pizza
[Music]
all right hope you guys are enjoying the
video so far and right now I'm gonna
give you three options of giant foods to
make for season two so number one we
have a giant sushi roll number two we
have giant spaghetti meatballs and
number three we have a giant grilled
cheese so let me know which one of the
three is your favorite leave it in the
comments below
I'm gonna take a look at it I'm gonna
choose one of them to make for the
season and enjoy the rest of the video
Oh gonna be like 20 times the size of a
normal ball around open your eyes
[Music]
hi welcome back
the tasties making it big I'm Alvin and
I love making the giant food personally
I've been a fan of sumo wrestling for a
very long time
I've always wondered you know how do
they train what do they eat how do they
maintain that athletic prowess at such a
size so today I've invited yamas on from
the USA sumo to come in so let's go meet
him and see what he wants to eat thank
you for coming in I've always wanted to
meet a similar wrestler like you can you
tell me what it's like to be a sumo
wrestler very hard but very nice what is
the training like so we wake up at 6
a.m.
training he finishes at noon 6 hours of
training yeah very important after eat
sleep why why do you sleep make big body
yeah eat and then sleep
are there any misconceptions you know
about sumo that you think need to be
addressed
[Music]
Zankou hood avocados intimately Canary
cohere Cena heresy hood of a character a
today Cara don't cook today
so look what I got chicken soup one of
my dreams is to cook for a sumo wrestler
like you what giant food would you like
me to make for you today can you make me
vomit gyrometer
yeah what kinds of ingredients do you
like in your ramen cashew egg okay
green onion okay
what kind of broth do you like kumquats
don't cut me too that's my favorite
Thanks okay I have to think about this
might be tough but I think I can do it
oh thank you appreciate it
so uh I don't have to do I got to make a
giant egg I got to make homemade ramen
broth big giant ramen noodles and
somehow make a giant pork and honestly
it's kind of a lot to deal with I think
I'm gonna have to call in some backup I
got a friend in mind that I think could
really help me out so I'll be right back
this is my friend Inka she's a producer
at BuzzFeed she's have made some amazing
videos you might have seen a lot of the
cool stuff that she's done she's amazing
in the kitchen
pink welcome thank you thank you have
you ever made ramen before I have not
made ramen I've made other kinds of
noodles like Tony's noodle soup okay um
stir-fry noodles well you have a lot
more experience than I do so I'm glad
you're here today we're gonna make a
giant ramen full disclaimer this isn't
anything particularly new channels have
done similar versions but we want to do
our own take on it I think well the
first thing we're gonna do is make the
broth so we're gonna make a ton katsu
breath you have a lot of a meat pork
feet chicken backs chicken necks a lot
of kind of odds and ends and pieces
the reason why they use these odd cuts
is because I think it adds a lot of
flavor right it's a good way to use up
like the normal cuts you when I just eat
the
alright Wow what the meets a water going
into the back toilet clean off any
impurities I'll be right back okay so
while the bones and meat are blanching
we are going to charge some vegetables
and the reason we do this is so that we
can add some smokiness to the flavor at
some depth you know I'd like to bring
that heat alright listen to that sizzle
this is like three pounds of onions like
25 cloves of garlic that's what I like
to see when I take a while because
there's a lot of vegetables that we have
to go through yeah look great all right
so nice and caramelized it's about 10
minutes I took a nap you know made her
do all the hard work but I got you a
tray if you don't show your vegetables
that's also okay but all these like
black bits here it really enhances the
flavor right it's like flavor bits yeah
flavor business we have our hard
vegetables Thank You Inka for making it
happen I'll make sure I put more work in
so this group project doesn't become a
failure yeah this is what the bones look
like after being boiled and skimmed a
bit so we're just gonna take them out
time to go fishing you see that layer of
fat that's how much stuff came out of it
this has a lot of impurities and kind of
the weird bits from the bones not really
that great to save so I'm gonna go dump
this out so we can get a cleaner broth
going
I'll leave the heavy labor to you sure
yeah literally carry my weight we have
to put the bones back in here we go oh
that's bladdered so we have the charred
vegetables really err shiitake mushrooms
love these these are so good in every
type of broth
ready those these are what is done what
what are those these are leeks
okay 1 2 3 go make it rain
well this is like what 3 bunches of
scallions we got your vegetables
children thanks mom I'll get a higher
than you can
this is gonna need to cook for like 8 to
12 hours because it's like a really nice
brought that cooks for a long time
basically slowly simmering it I'm gonna
take this into the back to cook we're
gonna make some ramen noodles was
scratch as you guys can see we have a
couple of ingredients here flour water
and counselee also known as lye water
it's a sort of alkaline solution I don't
want to get too scientific here but what
it does it makes noodles chewy
that's what gives it that sort of like
springy mouthfeel I've never made these
before alright let's just get to it
so it's kind of like pasta but like
there's no egg right picking up on
spring it comes back I feel like since
you did a lot of the work with the
vegetables I gotta pull my weight you
know you can't be the guy in the goo
projects that just like sits bag does
nothing and then just like shows up on
the last day I was like oh hey guys
how's it going oh you finished oh thanks
thanks for the ate Alvin talks a lot
sorry it's the first time I've had a
friend on the show you're just lonely
and me that's true you can tell that
there's a lot of what is it gluten
gluten yes there is a lot of gluten
because it's taking a lot of like arm
work good okay you're literally like
it's nice and you don't slap I mean how
else do you check of it smooth I'm gonna
say this is done how do you feel we just
need it let it rest a little relax a
little and then we can roll it out in
tune some moons all right let's go yes I
always know is dramatic as I thought
I'll take how do you think that that's
satisfying oh yeah
yeah it's like a mochi ice cream it is
good time mochi ice cream would not
taste like it two out of ten do not
recommend we're just flattening out so
then it can go through the pasta machine
all right so this is currently set at
zero zero is the thickest setting we're
gonna start with that and then see we
can go from here oh come on look at mine
all right you go first
there we go that's the beginning it has
to be a gradual process slowly you get
it thinner and thinner which is why
we're going wet from zero to seven to
seven like many times it's pretty
labor-intensive this is why you need to
people in push squish squish we have the
fettuccine attachment I'm gonna put the
crank over here and then if you want to
feed it through
okay got it
ooh got it you guys okay that's one I
use my dough might be here for a couple
of hours
ratha is still cooking eight to twelve
hours is a very long time so we're gonna
get started on the pork the chashu we
have a pork belly here I think it's a
beautiful piece of meat
let's get gloves on because this might
get a little bit messy rolling it up
because you know how when you go to
ramen shops you see that perfect circle
of meat that's what we're trying to
replicate we're gonna need to tie it
though because if you roll it up yasss
to do that so how about one person ties
the other person has to hold it together
all right hold it tight hold it tight
roll it up tight you want to go under
the meat and then oh wait that's how
came out well it's slippery hmm oh geez
a key one here we go
oh no fingers are lost today all right
we have it in the pot we're gonna add
the braising liquid the soy sauce whirs
I know it looks like a lot of soy sauce
remember this is a giant pork roll yeah
like three bunches of scallions in here
this is sake save some for me
Helmand would run off with this then the
sweet wine meeting and garlic
I got your ginger look at that good
timing
well add a little bit of water to top it
off we're gonna braise this for a while
until it gets really nice really tender
the fats gonna come out and all of that
sauce that just went in there it's gonna
seep right into the meat goodbye pork
baby you ready for this I want to see
you how our pork babies
all right let's bring this to the tray
gently all right the baby has landed
it's very tender it's very tender
cheers Cheers hmm beautiful we're saving
it because we are actually going to
marinate our egg in this sauce no ace
yeah all right you want to take care of
that I want to start wrapping this okay
we have something very special this is
an ostrich egg and this is a normal egg
for reference you know it's kind of like
you versus the guy she tells you not to
worry about this is not easy to break
and you've had like experience with
ostrich eggs
yes I have I have made an ostrich egg
egg McMuffin before yeah this feels like
a grenade like there's no finish okay
sumo wrestler said he wanted a nice soft
boiled egg that's kind of white ramen
comes with a sec nice right it's like
beautiful it's marinated I think we're
gonna have to resort to a technique
called subida essentially it's
circulating water around the egg at a
fixed temperature to cook it even all
the way through this is gonna go in the
water do you want to give it a name eggy
okay cute xev eggies gonna hang out in
the water we're gonna cross her face and
wait for a couple of hours and see what
goes on here we are three hours later
I'm just nervous I mean I know he's been
sitting in there for a long time
soft-boiled though yeah I don't know if
it's gonna work but there's no other way
to find out then to take it out and
crack might open gentle gentle a cured
we're gonna use the back of the knife
here where's more blunt and just slowly
hack away at it
ready ready whenever you are it's very
soft it's like jello okay it's
definitely not cooks this is not what a
soft-boiled egg because I think the yolk
cooks way faster than whites and Suvi is
all about cooking at a human temperature
right so there's no real way you can
Suvi it where this is under and this is
over I think we might have to sacrifice
a soft-boiled egg and just go with a
hardener boil it's better to be safe and
edible if it's not soft-boiled I think a
Masai will understand I would think he
would appreciate the fact that he is
eating an egg in not jello eggy I served
as well he has served as well thank you
for his sacrifice may you rest in pieces
[Music]
moment of truth you need help eat it
okay
emotional support wouldn't be bad there
good job Elvan you've got this well you
can do it Elvan so we got a second one
what do you want to name it he junior
just for good luck
oh you wanna do the honors no you gave
him a face I feel he's just looking at
me with the eyes one shot right this is
one shot yes is the last so it continues
to hammer his head with a knife
oh okay it's not let's focus on let's
focus on this side this is a hard-boiled
ostrich egg not the prettiest thing but
hey you know sometimes children don't
turn out the way you want them to and
that's okay we love them all the same we
should marinate this right yes okay we
have that down to the marinade we're
gonna add some more soy sauce to this to
help cover it so we can get a full-on
bath you don't want any white sauce
we're probably gonna leave this sitting
in there overnight I would say the damn
thick egg it is day 2 this has been
cooking for 12 hours let's go let's do
it oh I smell so good that is delicious
oh dear a OD but we can eat everything
in here all of this stuff went into that
broth so you know the broth is gonna
taste good look at this nice and like
milky consistent
oh dear oh dear all right all right so
it's slow oh we did it it's delicious
yeah I think we can always add more salt
and more flavor later and we want it
like such as that sauce from the braise
I mean as Alvin says go big or go home
that's what I like to hear let's go pork
baby he's back it seems like it's
holding its shape fairly well gloves one
two three one two three
[Music]
that's a spiral of joy right there all
right that's one slice number two
oh no not one of the most beautiful
things you've ever seen that's six
slices hopefully that is enough for this
very amazing man it is time to assemble
we have our beautiful eggy jr. here he
has been sitting in this little soy
sauce meeting socket back for a while we
have the pork belly
ginger nori seaweed scallions and
obviously the broth but more importantly
enjoy my ramen calls for it's like the
one my mom has it home like every Asian
family has a version of this and a pair
of pretty lone chopsticks to go with our
pretty big bowl oh so dark
Wow this marinade really like sink in
Wow you want to cut the I can hold it
for you I don't cut your hand these are
tasty hands they're valuable actually
you know what all right cool good bye
eggy whoa this guy's tough wait hold up
kind of break them open whoa cheers oh I
think the next thing we should do is to
sear the pork belly add some color to it
like how it looks in like ramen shop we
could sear it in a pan or pop in the
oven or
time to get lick oh yeah all right agent
Lam proceed to target one copy that fire
will status report agent Lam target is
slowly burning huh
target known as pork baby is proving to
be quite resilient but there are signs
of distress to be annihilated oh good
like the fat is crisping a really nice
so fun something about fire smoke meat
and fat it's like my favorite thing in
the world look at that this is the best
day ever
we are now entering the noodle zone so
we have the noodles from yesterday we
have a pot of boiling water here and we
have an ice bath after I cook them I
dump it in ice water just so it lowers
the temperature and so it won't continue
cooking how many servings do you think
we're actually making here I think that
this big giant ramen bowl is gonna be
like 20 times the size of a normal bowl
of ramen this is the final mission we
should save the brach for last probably
build everything else first starting
with the noodles like that
yes poop right here I'll help you get
the nori in this beautiful pork coming
in hot
last piece I'm going in the prettiest
girl at the prom all right let's do the
eggs get it against the wall all right I
want again right other egg is going nice
Oh No
tip it over I'll do that Tokyo scallions
you can touch some pickled ginger there
it is this is our oven this is this is a
ramen this is one woman for a one minute
well we got a lot of liquid and I don't
think we have a lot of space to do this
yes what's the strategy here the
strategy is there is no strategy we wait
for it until it's full I like this
strategy we're just gonna put in this
the braising sauce first okay okay now
when I go in with some broth it's hot
that didn't even make a dent good thing
we've made a lot of broth here we go
again
good job good job
this is actually the most victorious I
felt it's making a giant burger I think
this is done you think we're ready to
serve Jamison I think use a very hungry
guy and I really want to see if what we
made stacks up to what he expects
because we put a lot of work that's why
yeah you have my respect
ramen makers out there oh and we did
good good good I would go clean up close
your eyes go go go almost there almost
there then turn around
okay okay one two three
open your eyes
[Music]
we have that tonkotsu broth with a
homemade ramen noodles big cashew on
ostrich egg this this this is for you
thank you how do you feel
[Music]
are you hungry
yeah very hungry thank you
[Music]
[Music]
I would do this all over again in a
heartbeat harder so yeah do you think do
you think you can finish at all
are you counting to everything okay so
I'm sure my friends are coming in
oh yeah okay you're my grand akitoki Oh
[Music]
you know today I just so very thank you
so much thank you we did it thank you
for helping me today could definitely
not done it without you the name of the
show is taste he's making a big I really
don't think could have gotten any bigger
today a lot of time and effort but I
think I really paid off
it was really fun if you want to guess
what we're gonna be making leave a
comment send us a message thank you so
much and we will see you guys next time
until then peace
[Music]
so we have 78 eggs six sticks of butter
I have never whipped this many egg
whites until hit this is like when
you're swimming and you're doing
breaststroke my hand feels like it's
literally in a cloud we go this one's
for all the monies
[Music]
hi my name is Alvin I am a tasty
producer and I love making giant food
for other people today I'll be bringing
in my friend jasmine who is a host on
bring these giant food thyme or she is
surprising her friends with giant foods
at restaurants I want to return the
favor and also see if anything that I
can make will stack up against all the
amazing and huge things that she's
gotten to eat so let's go meet her good
how are you good are you hungry I'm
hungry and excited so for the people
that don't know you what do you exactly
do I am also very familiar with giant
food I surprise my friends with giant
foods but I take them to locations that
already serve them and then I invite my
friends in and I make their dreams come
true so basically you do the exact same
thing that I do except for you go to a
restaurant yeah instead yeah I don't
have to do any other work sounds pretty
darn efficient if you were to request me
to make you any giant version of any
food ever what would you like okay I'm
actually sweating just thinking about it
so I saw a video on tasty about a jiggly
cheese cake why are you laughing I made
that video okay perfect why are you such
a big Japanese jiggly cheese cake fan
it's just this golden-brown beauty you
know and then you take it out of the
oven and it's like steaming and you
jiggle it it jiggles as much as my belly
jiggle is just like that I will not
bring you the giant cheesecake unless it
jiggles this is something that I think
is gonna be pretty fun I've made a
recipe for this before and I think we
should just try to make a pretty large
version of it so the first thing we're
gonna do we're just gonna make a liquid
batter and that involves six sticks of
butter so not a diet food sorry just
look down whoo and then you can't have a
cheese cake without cream cheese oh man
that pudding cream cheese island and
we're gonna pour in the milk and whisk
it and I think that's gonna emulsify it
and make it smoother all right the one
hand constraining technique
all right this just makes sure that
there's not too many lumps because I
know who's dealing with a lot of cream
cheese and a lot of butters - the
liquids we're gonna add the dry
ingredients so this is just flour Oh got
some cornstarch
pretty intense battery got no matter how
many times I make giant food I always
forget how much about physical advocates
so again smooth is quite nice the entire
all right I'm gonna say that this batter
is pretty good pretty smooth I'm gonna
set this aside I want to take a break
whoa this is heavy
there's this pan okay so this is fun
well this is actually the same pan that
I had used for the original recipe video
but I'm sorry it will not be big enough
today so the pan that I'm actually gonna
be using this one over here this is a
hotel pan they use these pants to serve
like food at the face found what I
needed I hope this is gonna work and I
hope I'm in batter so I'm gonna go and
start whipping some eggs we have our pan
and the thing is we don't want our
cheesecake to stick so before we beat
any eggs I'm gonna line this pan with
parchment paper
shape these up right now okay so we have
essentially all the pieces we need to
make this cheesecakes parchment lining
work so we're gonna spray it and get
everything to stick together okay so we
got our pan that's lined
all right let's crack some eggs so we
have a 78 eggs because the secret to
this recipe is just a lot of egg whites
that's what makes it so fluffy and we
just need to separate them into whites
and yolks so I was lucky enough to be
able to go to Japan to work with our
tasty Japan team I also went with 3/8
essentially when we were planning our
trip we were like looking for videos on
what to do and we saw this like crazy
jiggly's Japanese cheesecake so we
actually went to the destination in the
video and in Japan a lot of their
restaurants and shops have glass doors
or glass windows but I wanted to figure
out how the heck they made this recipe
so I did was I was like hey ray can you
uh stand in front of that last window
over there and I was like yeah just pose
a little bit really thought she was just
like you know getting some nice pictures
at the shop and pointing at things and I
was like yeah yeah I understand yeah he
was actually doing and I wasn't taking
pictures at all no I was taking video
actually of what was going on behind Rea
and I was essentially trying to get as
close as I could to see what ingredients
they were putting into the batter so she
was there just you know really nice
didn't suspect a thing well I was going
full mission impossible incognito
essentially came back home to New York
and was like I need to figure out how to
make this cheesecake so I took a guess
at what ingredients they put in so I
would make a batch I would make the
batter
every attempt was two hours I would take
it out and then the real test was once I
took it out I would slap it a cold times
and if it jiggled it worked if it didn't
jiggle it was back to the drawing board
so I went through like 200 eggs for like
12 attempts and
I think I just you know randomly did
some research one night and drastically
changed the ratio of egg whites to egg
yolks and then after like 30 minutes in
the oven I was looking at and I was like
hey it was like blowing up like going
through puberty
I like set the Cheesecake down jiggled I
was like watch and I'm like whew that's
the jiggly cheesecake right there and
that is the story when I keep cracking
these eggs I'm gonna be an expert at
separating and cracking eggs after this
alright so we have 12 eggs left
uh-hum we've done 66 so far and because
we need 12 egg yolks for the actual
batter itself I want to say 12 in here
and then give these back to the kitchen
once I'm done it's time to win oh wait I
mean huh oh god wait hold on let's
separate the egg whites first yeah this
bowl is not getting big enough I'm gonna
split it into this bowl so I'm gonna
eyeball around 1/2 mmm delicious
all right cool now it's actually time to
whip so I'm gonna get these back in here
1 2 I have never whipped this middy egg
whites into my head there we go
how'd I get a wider stance to stabilize
myself this is like when you're swimming
and you're doing breaststroke
I don't know if you guys can tell but
sort of a brief kind of happy
all right there get into kind of fluffy
I'm gonna take a break we're gonna stop
for now I want to sprinkle in some sugar
I'm so tired
okay this one's getting some sugar
I just gotta get some sugar - everybody
get some sugar so the sugar acts as a
stabilizer as well for the egg whites
framing for a soft peaks here would you
want this to be a fluffy cheesecake
actually getting light pink honey some
oxygen oh I really lightheaded right now
we need some help
let's just could I get some help about a
blackout it sounds very lightheaded
could you help me do that one well I do
this one I mean I feel like we're almost
there
we're almost there I just don't want to
collapse okay okay
I'm into it I think this is good let's
do it that's really silky thank you so
much for your help without that I'd be
on the floor right now but thank you I
appreciate it I'll need it I'm gonna
fold these into the batter we made
earlier and to be honest I don't think
there's a utensil large enough to fold
these into the egg whites so I might
have to use my arms are you gonna throw
me wash my arms never what I think I'd
be using my hearse as cooking utensils
but
all right arms are washed I'm gonna fold
the egg whites into the batter but first
we gotta take these foam egg yolks and
mix them back into the OD batter
these boys are going in add some fat and
texture to this so it's gonna go quick
because egg whites to play super fast
whoo all right this batter is ready to
be folded into the egg whites so we're
gonna scoop some mankiewicz oh my god
this is so fun already we're just going
to fold trying to keep this as sanitary
as possible so it's already getting a
little lighter my hand feels like it's
literally in a cloud we're gonna get the
rest of these Oh me here we go this is
why so I'm gonna say you that this is
good for the batter
I was fun I could wash my hands we're
gonna pour this batter into the pan and
cross our fingers to hope that it does
stay exactly the same way that we want
it to and let's do it to actually bake
this thing in the old video I did a
water bath so we're gonna try to
replicate that because I think that
helps the Cheesecake cook a lot more
evenly I got a little like a setup here
I'm gonna do like an inch or so of water
not too much we don't want it to
actually touch the bottom of the pane so
we're gonna put like a little filter
that goes in and then probably one of my
favorite parts putting the batter into
the pan we go
[Music]
wait that's awesome I'm going to put
this on top or the water grab this okay
and then smooth it out with an offset
spatula to make sure everything is okay
you know get rid of any of the really
really big air bubbles alright
this is jiggly cheesecake batter there's
a lot of it I want to very carefully
take this into the oven why is this so
heavy it's just egg whites so from my
previous recollection of the original
Japanese jiggly cheesecake it's
basically a giant souffle so there is
like no time to waste the moment it
comes out of the oven I'm gonna run it
over here I'm gonna flip it out as fast
as and as safe as possible so it's gonna
be hot it's gonna be big
there won't be any time to spare these
are gonna get pretty intense I might be
in full crazy Alvin mode so if I don't
say anything that's because the focus
you don't make the food look good I'm
pretty nervous for it
so here we go oh all right well this top
is really smooth this is looking pretty
cool alright here we go
out of the water bath Oh so let's get
this that's there good grip here we go
guys this one's for all the money's
Oh holy [ __ ]
[Music]
holy-moly has got to go back one more
time so we can get it on to the other
train all right II got this whoo whoa
that's a jiggly cheesecake right there
oh my god I love it so much
all right I got I got some parchment cuz
I'm gonna do some powdered sugar make it
rain as we usually do it's so cool
I'm so happy it worked I think this is
it we did it
this is particularly Japanese cheesecake
look at that hey I want to stop doing
them so surprised Jasmine yeah yeah on
some particularly cheesecake yeah well
here you go
I have a regular one take it in so
please close your eyes okay when I count
to three I want you to open your eyes
and see the cheesecake okay one two
three
glad you like it yeah I think you're
like you're your god
oh thanks homie you want eat this thing
yeah all right let's get in here how
about you cut himself a bigger slice
just saying hey is it not you oh my
curve well I'll give the bigger one to
you thank you all right well here you go
Oh
[Music]
all right well here's your piece thank
you please eat while it is still warm
good yeah how do you feel on the
receiving end I'm quitting my show
don't say that go have you gone down in
the cross section yet no well I'll give
you see here right there's almost like a
custard flan kind of action mm-hmm going
on so you get more textures mmm
well I'm glad you liked it thanks for
coming on the show I'm glad two people
that love giant food finally got to hang
out and eat a giant food together so
this has been great curve Cheers hmm Oh
God
well we're doing it I mean jiggly she's
gay I don't jiggle not have to wiggle
very happy in the way it turned out
almost blacked out in a certain point
but I'm glad I got Alexis to come in and
pull through Jazmin seemed pretty happy
about it and I was just so excited to
see her face and her reaction to it
because she loves giant food just as
much as I do
if you have any guesses to what I'll be
making next any comments any suggestions
you know any ideas that you think you
want me to make it to a giant reality
feel free to leave a comment below a 70
Instagram message I'll see what I can do
but you know until next time
[Music]
it's a absolute unit of cheese we got
going on it's like 15 cups of parmesan a
lot of onions to get through a lot of
tears to cry whoo
take a breather not really sure why I'm
doing this but helps
hi my name is Alvin
I am a tasty producer and I love making
giant food for other people for the past
two years I've been playing video games
with a couple of friends from work and
this one guy Jake he is always eat like
before we play while we play after we
play all the time so I thought it'd be
kind of fun to make him something giant
for him to snack on because this guy
eats a lot
let's go me jaqen see what he wants to
eat today dude what even up to you know
just same old work in yeah hard so I've
told people that we play games online a
lot yes and also you are always eating I
just always like to have is that why
you're like always better than video
eating I think there's a correlation
yeah I also do want to make you a giant
food so is there anything in particular
that you think would be fun to just
snack on I mean I love fried foods okay
my Mike my main finger food is uh like
mozzarella sticks okay how about one of
you what if I made you both mozzarella
sticks but honey drinks I feel like they
go together like onion rings actually
with my gateway into onions you don't
like onions before and then onion rings
I was like it is not bad I think I can
get into it gotta go make these giant
mozzarella sticks and giant onion rings
and hopefully then I could beat you as
well because maybe you'll be too
preoccupied
yeah that's manner you can feel free to
hang out here I'm gonna get to it and
see if I can make that happen
all right thanks do appreciate it yeah
yeah yeah okay
so today we're gonna be making giant
onion rings you also might have seen
them on some other YouTube channels so
it's not exactly the newest concept but
we're gonna try to make our own version
so my technique is basically instead of
making one like giant onion ring is to
shape onions into a ring instead and not
have to deal with finding a ring that's
like this big so I'm just gonna
I'm gonna throw a couple of these here
is a lot of onions I can smell it
already
oh yeah we're gonna need some tissues
over here I'm going to actually sprinkle
some salt in it because I want to draw
out as much water as I can because I
don't want the onion ring to be really
wet that's delicious
as you can see if you have a bit of a
onion puree going on we're actually just
gonna dump it into a bowl with
cheesecloth I'm gonna do this a couple
more times that's looking pretty good
round twos done this is the onion puree
mixture that we have I don't think I can
put the rest of this in there yet so I'm
actually just gonna take this out and
squeeze it to get all the juices I'm
really getting it everywhere all right
Ivan you can do this blindfolded
spilling like a diaper yeah yeah so a
lot of Tears right now I think the last
time I cried this much I washed the
venders and Game of Thrones in the same
night that's pretty intense oh my god
okay actually I think this is making me
cry a little oh all right I want to say
it's good for round number one
whoa take a breather
I'm Fanning my own eyes I want to power
through it you know no one ever said
this was gonna be easy you know
sometimes it doesn't kill you makes you
stronger fingers crossed this doesn't
take me out but we'll see it's actually
good kind of a tense little grin
oh okay
that's nice we're gonna keep going and
thank you appreciate it you're a real
fan I can't get over the amount of
liquid coming out though that's just
wild so let's see okay good
yes nice ball of squeezed out onions
whoa okay I had to take a little nap in
the back eyes are killing me our fan is
still on but we're gonna add some
binders in here to make this into a ring
so I have some cornstarch and I have
some bag why I'm just gonna keep mixing
until all the moisture absorbs start
with this much actually really nice and
soft to play with gotta make the hole in
the middle there we go get into the ring
kind of shape hopefully it holds
together in the freezer shaping it it's
coming together I think that's a pretty
good-looking onion ring we got going on
okay I'm gonna make one more I have high
hopes for this one their strategy is to
get this into a nice circle and then
make the hole in the middle got to be
good the fingers here cuz you got to
shape it into a nice hole like a
doughnut I say that these are two pretty
nice-looking onion rings we got some
more of this onion batter I want to take
these into the freezer and then we're
gonna get some stuff ready and probably
go work on some mozzarella sticks so
here we go
onion rings are in the freezer in the
meantime we're gonna make giant
mozzarella sticks
we got like six pound blocks
oh my god Oh to bisect this in entire
log we got here okay look at that
alright next cut these down there you go
when you it was so hard to cut the
cheese that's some big sticks we got
we're gonna cut these all up first there
we go okay we got four blocks turn these
into some sticks we could you know it's
batter and fry this one I honestly don't
think that's big enough so I'm gonna try
to get these two to go back-to-back I
think this might be easier if I break
this in half all right there you go okay
we gotta get another one to cross over
these are skewered together we're gonna
put them in the freezer to set up and
you know I'm gonna hang out in the back
probably gonna eat half of this turn the
rest of this into more mozzarella sticks
so I'll be back we have to make the
breading that's like a landslide over
here they call this the big summit of
panko well ask an avalanche in a
rainstorm of grated Parmesan cheese but
this is mozzarella stick and it tastes
pretty damn good I'll tell you that and
you know just some salt as we got us
still season your stuff then dry parsley
flakes for color and for a little bit of
flavor it was gonna get in here whisk
all this together
oh that turn into like a landscape I'm
gonna say at least probably ten loaves
of bread were used to make these
breadcrumbs pretty much there now we
gotta whisk our thirty-two eggs
look at this beautiful color we've got
going on all right so I'm gonna go grab
those mozzarella sticks and we're gonna
probably make a huge mess trying to
bread them but we're gonna do it for
Jake let's go make it happen okay well
we have four skewer together jive
mozzarella sticks I think it's time to
bread them this is a 100% going to get
very messy so put on some gloves here we
go go in here cook them in the egg all
righty I'm just gonna throw these on
here I'm gonna do that but this is the
biggest thing I think I've ever breaded
here at tasty in the back of the eggs
get coated flip it around back in the
breadcrumbs oh here we go okay it's
getting skin a little coat I'm into it
okay this guy's pretty much ready
that was one we're gonna do a couple
more all right here we go number two oh
this is pretty nerve-racking yes yeah
these are four giant mozzarella sticks
we got some extra breading
I might go make some more because you
know I think it's always fun to have
more cheese I'm gonna take two these to
the freezer see you guys later okay
oh it's like the pancakes cool i nearing
batters so got a big bowl of flour here
then we're just gonna add in our
seasoning so got some cool seasoning
salt and regular salt some pepper and
whisking it together hit a nice color in
there all right that's in and we're
gonna go with boil a lot of eggs and
then just a lot of milk cool I like
living life on the edge you know
oh the momentum from the hips helps to
better not drip I'm gonna take this to
the back and I get some help because I'm
pretty much exhausted and I'm gonna go
to bed good night guys as you can see
this is a very large pot with a lot of
hot oil please do not try this at home
I'm very excited to see how this all
turns out and let's get to it okay let's
go here one on this is the mozzarella
stick we're going in folks
snow there goes we are frying at around
three ninety four hundred degrees this
is gonna fry for about I'm gonna say
like two to three minutes it doesn't
take a long time so we'll give it a
look-see oh let's look good real good
run really quick oh right we might be
able to take this guy out let's get in
here with one of these you got this guy
alright this is our mozzarella stick
screed our golden brown now we're coming
out whoo that's a mozzarella stick okay
we made two more mozzarella sticks so
now we have four and now we're gonna
move on to onion rings so this is gonna
go into the cornstarch and absorb any
excess moisture from the onions I'm
gonna ask for Seth tell Ryan can you
give me a hand here this is Ryan he's on
our culinary team he's amazing and he's
the reason why this video is going to
work you want to hold the bowl right
next to the oil this will be a two-man
effort go in
mm that's kind of cool okay thanks for
holding Ryan so let's see if we can get
this under here we got a drip off any of
the excess you got in the back here goes
nothing guys
whoo all right well that's what you can
do with the power of teamwork Thank You
Ryan this is at around 350 or so 370 ish
because there were onions inside our raw
so we need to cook them through just
like an onion ring so this is gonna fry
I want to say like 10 to 15 minutes
until it's golden brown and crispy and
we're gonna check back on it okay it's
been 15 minutes the color is really nice
I think that looks like an onion ring
coming out
all right I got probably two more to go
because you can't have a complete set
without four rings in four sticks so got
a lot more batter to go through see you
guys in a bit
we did it tried a lot of stuff we got
400 rings we've got four mozzarella
sticks but I think it's time to really
assemble these just like Captain America
says we got some really cool containers
for the onion rings this guy's goes
first right hanging out this guy coming
over here then we're gonna get my boy
onion ring number three and then final
guy those are the four onion rings
let's go plate the mozzarella sticks all
right one two three all right this one
goes in the back to finish it off to
make it look really delicious you know
why not there's some make it right and
parmesan on top and then we're gonna
make it rain parsley - yeah this is
pretty awesome guys mozzarella sticks
are finished they were plated there we
have it we have giant monster elastics
giant onion rings regular marinara sauce
just a lot of it I think Jake super
hungry say no more let's go eat
hey Jake what's up dude are you ready
for your food yeah the end let's see it
alright close your eyes though alright I
want to bring them in one by one I wanna
see my mouth is already salivating a bit
food is in front of you ok hope you're
hungry I think you might be very happy
with the results so on the count of
three I want you to open your eyes
alright alright one two three open your
eyes dude oh my god that is a huge yeah
pretty good right there's enough for you
to eat on wall you figure each so I'll
crush at least a few of these I hope so
he's gonna be eating a lot dude yes yes
yeah we have some giant mozzarella
sticks got some giant onion rings and we
have some homemade marinara homemade oh
my go you're gonna dream the best part
about a mozzarella stick is you know
when you pull it you get that great
Gigi's pull if you want one two three
give it a nice pull slow oh oh good
mozzarella
this is some oh my god it keeps going oh
yes crazy oh here we go
alright well I got a dip first yeah yeah
of course you can dip
I dip you dip we all did I don't know
what that song goes but that's what it
is
alright alright cheers dude is man okay
hmm
Wow
who is it dude this is unreal this
tastes so good it's good right it's like
a mantra stick sandwich this is like the
best thing ever it's like an innovative
dish you want always onion rings - oh
whoa all right yeah I'm just gonna dual
dip mmm well ha
so how it just made it good yeah yeah
I'm good on you in there how do you feel
like you're good heaven good God
well I'm happy I could make this for you
I know you guys might be playing some
games later you know if you want to
bring this to the guys a lot of food oh
oh yeah well I'll help you bring this
over all right all right you man yeah
yeah it's been a tough day today you
know we uh cried a lot I sweat it a lot
but I would say it's pretty successful
Jake was happy I was very impressed with
just how far the mozzarella pool got I
think that was probably one of my
favorite China food so far and you know
this is the second-to-last episode of
the season of making a big if you guys
want to take a guess at something cool
that I have prepared for you guys next
week feel free leave it in the comments
send me a message it's gonna be kind of
crazy and I think you'll know the person
that I'm making it for but until next
time
[Music]
make you fancy Alvin no this is a 100
much it's a damn lot of eggs it's a lot
of time cut out to all my hands out
there in the real ones
alright sleepy there's two together one
two great open your hi today I'm Alvin
I love making food today on tasties
making it big we're gonna do some crazy
stuff today I'll be cooking for my
fellow tasty producer r EA you might
have seen her on worth it on eating her
feed and a lot of other tasty videos
she's an amazing producer and it
wonderful chef I want to see if I can
make something that's really cool
that'll really impress her so let's go
see what she wants to eat today hello
how's it going did you have any lunch or
dinner plans today
I don't have lunch I do to have
breakfast leaving okay I'm very hungry
what do you personally enjoy like eating
on a day to day basis I love Japanese
breakfast okay rice miso soup and
tamagoyaki we choose japanese-style
omelet the one where they like cook it
in the pan and rolls up exactly okay so
I would be so impressed if you made a
meat omelet like a giant omelet jayam
lat well just to be clear though like
American omelets and Japanese almonds
are different right like what makes them
so unique so Japanese omelette it's like
you explained it's like rolled and it's
layered Americana has a lot of fun
ingredients like peppers caramelized
onions bacon and cheese are those like
your favorite ingredients in almonds
yeah I love Kamaraj onion and bacon
combination doesn't seem like is going
to be very easy make you fancy Alvin oh
no oh I have an idea yeah not only I'm
gonna make you a giant omelet what if I
make you a 100 eggs omelet 100 eggs on
100
it would be so amazing okay yeah okay
I'm gonna get to it okay here we are as
you can see I have many many many eggs
I have never purchased handled or seen
this movie in one place in my entire
life so the first step to making a 100
egg omelet is to crack 100 eggs so let's
get crackin hey hey oh I broke the first
one we were off to a fantastic start to
crack eggs want to take the egg and you
want to crack it on a flat surface
not on the edge of a pan or a bowl
because it could really shatter the
inside knock knock who's there you know
just an egg sometimes people ask me what
came first chicken or the egg after
hours of deliberation and don't really
know fun fact
hen lays one egg every 26 hours so that
means for one hand until a 100 eggs that
would that would be hot damn am Asian I
should be knowing this better days a
hundred and eight days and eight hours
for one hand to lay 100 eggs also known
as damn long time shout out to all my
hands out there you the real ones we're
almost there been quite a journey number
100 whoa okay we have officially cracked
100 eggs into this bowl it's a damn lot
of eggs it's a lot of time Thank You
chickens for your hard work
see you in a bit
so these are hundred eggs we're gonna
whisk them and I'm gonna season them
later I'm actually very excited for this
we're gonna go just little bitty eggs I
can't even get home I want to make sure
this is the smoothest egg mixture
anybody has ever seen so I want to wish
the crap out of these it's a workout
right arms getting real tired about now
oh they're ozone yoga mist there you go
I got you let's try you don't escape for
me I eat yolks for breakfast slowing
down it's not a vortex anymore
it's a kiddie pool I want to say that's
pretty much done you know we got it nice
and consistent color we're all good
we're gonna add some salts I don't know
how much salt to put in because it's 100
eggs so I kind of eyeball it I wanna say
that's enough going to transfer these
and start rolling our omelet my
technique for making this omelet is
similar to the Japanese style which is
called it tamagoyaki I think it's going
to be a controlled omelet so what I'm
gonna do is we have two of these trays
line with Silpat to make sure doesn't
stick I'm just gonna brush this with a
lot of butter butter and eggs you know
fantastic marriage obviously you know we
could dump 100 eggs you know into a pan
maybe but kind of boring you know it's
not what I do I have no idea that this
is going to stay upright if it's gonna
break but it's all good we're going to
basically try to pour some eggs in here
I'm gonna guess like a quart of eggs per
container mmm delicious
oh yes nothing like pouring liquid eggs
let's go evenly it's enough eggs enough
eggs I think it's enough eggs nice nice
nice
alright let's go for round two all right
I'm gonna go and take these to the oven
to bake I want it to set into an ice
sheet but I don't want it to overcook
we're gonna cook at 304 I'm gonna say
ten minutes I'm gonna very carefully
take this to the oven
all right album don't you mess this up
now your honor is on the line to not
displease reate okay we have nice uh-huh
big egg sheets here
this was a little lopsided I think in
the oven just kind of tips a little bit
that way it's okay you're gonna put some
cheese on it and I wash my hands so
we're all clean this is gonna go like
over here yeah here we go the heat from
the egg sheets are going to actually
help melt the cheese while it's being
rolled we're gonna do some bacon bits on
here I love bacon really likes bacon and
this is gonna be fun that's kind of
awesome and we're just gonna kind of go
for it and roll it and see if this works
so first you got to get it to go around
though keep it all tight yeah there we
go
all right is the sheet number one we're
gonna transfer it over to here we're
gonna do the same thing coming out then
landing it's going well so far
no major hiccups we're gonna keep going
okay and there you have it that's roll
number two edges looking a little floppy
that's okay
I want to need to reuse these chains
though so we're gonna transfer this onto
a board this is getting heavy already
whoa to keep this warm
when I cover it in some foil and then
we're gonna do two more trays hey each
one of these I think is around 20 eggs
hopefully I didn't miss measure
train number three and number four
twenty eggs apiece let's put it back in
the oven fingers crossed I can keep
rolling this without it breaking or
doing anything because surprisingly this
is going according to plan
all right these look pretty fantastic
fix a little oven adjustment so a little
bit smoother you got some nice American
cheese look at this beautiful stack it's
like I got the cheddar like in the rap
music videos load this guy up actually
very fun I'm a happy boy not too much so
for me this is it for this one
that wasn't gonna get him it's like I'm
painting but with food the thing is time
to roll we're gonna take the one we made
before then somehow get this onto here
slew all right well we've landed now
we're gonna start to roll again whoo
like that now it's getting kind of heavy
tuck it tuck it okay whoa smooth then
one more time all right okay kind of
crazy but you know we're all good keep
it together relatively well and now have
to get that guy onto here am i strong
enough to do this well come on all right
[Music]
successful landing solid is one big ball
all right and then one more time
oh the tray is tipping okay so uh we are
currently at 80 eggs this is getting
heavy whoo
I'm red is on the board still got a
little bit to go I'm gonna set this
aside and we're gonna go for the last 20
eggs oh oh okay so I think I might have
miscalculated how many eggs I need to
use portray this won't make enough for
two trays this is only gonna be enough
for like one and a half so we're going
big I think let's do 120 eggs I'm gonna
whisk this one more time to make sure
we're okay I don't know if you guys have
seen the honey layer of lasagna video I
ended up doing 104 layers on accident
kind of in my blood to go a little bit
over what I'm used to doing I'm trying
to impress reate hopefully she will be
impressed by the fact that I went have
above and beyond for her this is a
hundred eggs but you'll fill out that's
okay we're gonna whisk it back in okay
hundred and twenty eggs the final layer
might be a little heavier than most good
as it needs to be outer layer I want to
take this in to bake and we're gonna
hope that we can actually make this work
because if it's too big and it breaks I
would be very sad don't fail me now so
this is the fifth sheet a hundred eggs
this is the sixth one a hundred and
twenty I think they look beautiful
I think they look super smooth Rea loves
caramelized onions so we have
caramelized onions I also do want to put
a little bit more cheese because I think
it'll help bind the last layer I think
it's gonna taste pretty darn awesome a
lot of flavors going on he's got a
sweetness got creaminess you got
saltiness pretty much and every single
layer been a long journey I've used
probably like five pounds of Jesus at
this point I think it's gonna be pretty
awesome so you got a really heavy guy
over here we're gonna start rolling and
working that everything goes according
to plan
huh oh that was really heavy oh my god
this guy's getting massive well this
might be tough this is heavy I'm gonna
grip it right a hundred this little
extra legroom is gonna help we're gonna
move it on to 120 it all comes down to
this folks I don't know if you can tell
this is wobbly I need this guy to last
me one more and then we'll hope he okay
please don't fail me now come up okay
the reason I put this guy in the middle
because I want to fold this over and
then just do one last roll will be there
this is the big moment
last layer all right that is on all
right stay together stay together stay
together stay together all right we did
it
this is a 120 egg omelets
very big it is very heavy while it's
still warm I do want to serve it but I
also need to decorate it a little bit so
finish really likes chives and catch up
on her omelets I want to draw a face and
hopefully it looks kind of cool okay
then I gotta give this guy cheeks this
is my attempt to edit design not the
next Picasso but that's okay I'm gonna
finish this with a touch of chives just
in the front and in the back okay those
are the last of the chives it's been
crazy this is one heavy guy so we're
gonna go get this omelet to Ray airy a
yeah you ready for your omelet I'm ready
all right close your eyes please okay
I'm very excited to see what you think
on the count of three 1 2 3 open your hi
sorry I feel you're gonna make just the
America omelet if it's Japanese
it's actually not a hundred eggs ah 120
yeah
because I was like no what is gonna go
we could do one more I love it you owe
me to cut it open for you yes you want
to give it a name before we cut it in
half you're more than welcome to
well let's name this after your middle
name which is Karl with ecology
sorry Karl Wow but the lair this is what
it looks like on the inside
touching Karl I was powerful
oh it's very bouncy the car will give
you permission
here is your omelette thank you you
thought you might like your mouth hmm
Wow this deep colorful too so it sounds
like Carlos success Oh what's up selves
hmm you impressed me I'm happy I finally
got the chance to the freezer Thank You
sofa yeah anytime
please continue to eat okay I think
wrestle with the world should see this
okay
[Music]
well we did it guys we impress her ei a
lot of effort but I think it definitely
was worth it I think now I have a
newfound respect for eggs and this is it
this is the final episode and this
season Stacey's making a big it's been a
blast six episodes six crazy giant
dishes for six amazing people I'm super
happy that I got the chance to do this
I'm always gonna be trying to do bigger
and better things so until next time
peace
[Music]
you
[Music]